♪
♪ STEVE ALL RIGHT.
THE SQUALLERRED PICTURES KEEP
GETTING WORSE.
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS LIVING AS
YOU CAN SEE RIGHT THERE CAMPED
OUT IN A MASSIVE TENT CITY UNDER
THAT BRIDGE IN DEL RIO, TEXAS.
THE NEXT GUEST KNOWS THE AREA
WELL.
HE SERVED AS BORDER PATROL CHIEF
AND HE JOINS US DOWN IN TEXAS.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, STEVE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
STEVE: I'M DOING OKAY.
WE CALLED YOU IN BECAUSE WE HAVE
A BEST OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF
QUESTIONS.
OVER THE LAST TWO DAYS, THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
MAYORKAS HAS BEEN CALLED UP ON
CAPITOL HILL, HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE WE LETTING IN EXACTLY
ANSWERED GOES I DON'T KNOW THEY
GO HOW ABOUT A BALLPARK NUMBER?
I CAN'T EVEN GIVE A BALLPARK
NUMBER.
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS ASKED
YESTERDAY WE WILL GET THE NUMBER
TO YOU THIS AFTERNOON.
THAT WAS 18 HOURS AGO.
DO THEY KNOW THE NUMBER?
>> IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THOSE
NUMBERS AREN'T BE DOCUMENTED.
EVERY APPREHENSION GOES INTO THE
SYSTEM.
EVERY RELEASE GOES INTO THE
EVERYTHING IS CATALOGED SO FOR
SOMEBODY TO SAY THEY HAVE NO
IDEA I THINK IT'S A LITTLE
DISINGENUOUS.
>> WHERE ARE THEY SENDING
PEOPLE?
>> WELL, WHO KNOWS AND THAT'S A
PROBLEM INITIALLY THE STORY WAS
WE ARE MOVING THAT WE ARE HAVING
EXTRADITION FLIGHTS FROM THE
UNITED STATES TO HAITI THEN YOU
HEAR WE ARE NOTICE.
A NOTICE TO RESPOND INSTEAD OF A
NOTICE TO APPEAR.
IT DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME LEGAL
WEIGHT AS A NOTICE TO APPEAR.
IF SOMEONE DOESN'T SHOW UP TO
COURT DATE OR IMMIGRATION
APPOINTMENT THEN WE CAN ISSUE A
WARRANT OR ARREST FOR THEM.
THIS NOTICE TO RESPOND GOOD
FAITH.
ONLY 20% SHOW UP.
>> OLD DAYS LIKE 95% DIDN'T SHOW
UP.
SO MAYBE THE PROCESS HAS
IMPROVED.
STEVE: YEAH.
SO, HELP ME UNDERSTAND, WHY IS
THE ADMINISTRATION PLAYING DUMB
WITH THE NUMBERS AND NOT TELLING
US WHERE THEY ARE PUTTING
PEOPLE?
>> WELL, THAT BAFFLES ME, YOU
KNOW.
USUALLY YOU HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION AND WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT POLITICAL PHILOSOPHIES
ON WHICHEVER SIDE OF THE AISLE
YOU ARE ON.
BORDER SECURITY IS NOT A
POLITICAL ISSUE.
BORDER SECURITY SHOULD BE
EVERYBODY'S CONCERN.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WE ARE
CATCHING WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE'RE NOT CATCHING.
THE PEOPLE IN SECTOR ALONE OVER
200,000, I THINK, HONDURANS.
YOU HAVE ONLY HAD ABOUT 80,000
MEXICAN NATIONALS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPREHENDED HERE.
WE ARE OVER 520,000
APPREHENSIONS AT THIS SECTOR
COMPARED TO LESS THAN 80,000
LAST YEAR.
SO, WHAT, 500 AND SOMETHING
PERCENT INCREASE?
IT'S AMAZING THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES AND THEY ARE
COMING BECAUSE WE CREATED THE
MAGNET AND THE MAGNET IS CATCH
AND RELEASE AND THIS IS NOT A
HARD SOLUTION, I MEAN, IT'S NOT
A HARD PROBLEM TO SOLVE.
THE SOLUTION IS VERY EASY.
YOU DETAIN AND YOU REMOVE AND
YOU DELIVER CONSEQUENCES.
AND AS A RETIRED CHIEF RODNEY
SCOTT SAID A COUPLE DAYS AGO
WHEN HE SUBMITTED THAT LETTER TO
CONGRESS IS THESE SOLUTIONS HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED TO DHS HIERARCHY
AND THEY REFUSE TO IMPLEMENT IT.
STEVE: I THINK THEY WANT TO DO
IT THEIR WAY BUT THEIR WAY AS WE
SEE NOT WORKING ROSENDO,
HINOJOSA, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND JOINING US ON THIS
THURSDAY MORNING.
>> I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
AGENTS OUT THERE DOING THE JOB.
KEEP THE FAITH AND KEEP YOUR
HEADS UP.
STEVE: